[Music]
the third couple dancing in the finale
is Josh and Sharda Mariah now and you're
going home tonight
this was the most surprising thing of
this season so far for sure hands down
how you handling it and what's your big
takeaway from this experience summer I
did such a good job this whole season
end every week she really grew she
didn't just learn the steps she learned
how to dance and it was a lot of fun and
I'm gonna miss it most importantly of
all I am so grateful for this
opportunity and yes I'm very
disappointed but you know sometimes life
throws you lemons and you make lemonade
with it and next week I'll be back as
teams what are you gonna most remember
from your experience from your time on
the dance floor instead of the ice you
know I think that I really learned how
to perform and I really truly enjoyed it
I hope I hope I get more opportunities
like this because I loved every second
of it whether it was a difficult moment
and we had to fight to get past it it
wasn't easy for me to learn the dance
steps I've been waiting for this for a
long time and I can't I really truly
can't wait to see what's in the future
for me I think I've really grown as a
person and as a performer she's it
amazing ya know I think every day I
think score wise she was on top all the
time her dance was she was amazing I
mean who knows the way it happens
[Music]
[Applause]